summertime is almost here and younger
teenagers in georgia and pennsylvania
are already getting pfizer's covet
vaccine
after the fda's decision to authorize
emergency use
for 12 to 15 year olds other states are
expected to follow later this week
and it is just in time for summer camps
all across the country as they prepare
for campers to come back millions of
kids attend camp every year and many
will return
for the first time since 2019 because
last year's pandemic closures
meg oliver visited ymca camp mason in
hardwick new jersey to look at plans to
keep about 800 campers there
safe
[Music]
this year's summer at ymca camp mesa it
may not look
exactly like this but ceo keith
vanderzee says
they still plan to give kids the most
normal experience
they can the camp is always needed so
but this year it's going to be more
essential than ever we first met
vanderzee
last year shortly after they made the
difficult decision to cancel overnight
camp
the last time we sat down together you
were pretty devastated
how are you feeling today i'm feeling so
excited for this summer
that we can finally open again for our
121st
year they plan to follow state coveted
guidelines
kids must have a negative covid test
within 72 hours of arrival
then they'll test them again five days
into camp
and there will be additional hand
washing stations and sanitizer
big events like campfires will be social
distanced and campers will live and
interact in cohorts or small groups
of up to 20 kids when distancing
or indoors you will have to wear a mask
but our goal is to be outdoors as much
as possible
be in the cohort as much as possible and
mask-less as much as possible what
happens if a camper tests positive
we have had to set up isolation quarters
this year
we'll be notifying parents right away
quarantining is necessary
and making sure that camp is safe for
the rest of our population is it safe to
send your child to a summer camp this
summer
i think that most summer camps are
thinking very carefully about this and
would not be opening
if they felt that there was any
significant risk of harm
dr depression of zaria is helping
wisconsin summer camp develop reopening
guidelines
he says it's important campers are
cohorted and camp should try to do most
things outside
and he said there still should be some
social distancing
or masks in large groups outdoors
some people might wonder why are we even
talking about opening summer camps when
this pandemic is not completely over
our children need this even if it's not
completely normal
we think is really important to their
mental health and well-being mental
health is something camp mason is taking
very seriously
we actually have hired mental health
professionals to assist us this year
we have extended staff training where
we'll be covering a lot of aspects of
of grief and trauma and isolation when
you think about
camp what does camp mean to you it's
like kind of like a second home
new york city siblings aiden bella and
max tirado are counting down the days
until they're back at camp mason
they go every year and this year
17-year-old max
will be a staffer does camp mean even
more to you this summer after
what you've been through i think so i
feel like camp will give us a chance to
like escape what's happening
in the rest of the world for a little
bit bella what are you looking forward
to the most at camp
meeting new people and being able to
like socialize a bit more
because like i haven't been able to do
that really at home much
because of everything that's happening
amid everything that's happening
everyone seems ready to lean on some
sort of normalcy
[Music]
camp is going to be a place to heal for
some you know there's been real trauma
associated with covet
and camp is going to be a place where
kids can process their feelings
and i think you know the thing that
we're most excited about is just
reconnecting people
[Music]
camp mason will reopen june 27th they're
hopeful most of their staff will be
vaccinated
and some campers even if they're not
they're ready to welcome them back
safely that was meg oliver reporting
let's say
fingers eyes legs crossed that the kids
can go to camp this season let's all
hope for that